musique charlotte gainsbourg sur les
traces de son père un album intime et
intimiste salué par toute la presse le
disque sort demain olivier les musées
jean-marc cet après midi elle est
apparue timide et souriante loin de
l'engouement qu'elle suscite même le
sunday times consacre aujourd'hui sa une
à charlotte gainsbourg à l'occasion de
la sortie de son album
suite
charlotte gainsbourg s'est entouré d'une
équipe de rêve les français air quelques
anglais jonny cocker et le producteur de
radiohead tous fans de serge gainsbourg
un album pense qu'il faut prêter en
anglais les mots et avait trop de
résonance par rapport à aux textes mon
père et je critiquais trop j'étais très
j'étais très coincé avec les textes
français j'avais l'impression de que je
ferais que moins bien que lui
charlotte gainsbourg a vendu 20 ans
avant d'enregistrer son deuxième album
il y a longtemps au siècle dernier
une enfant vous deux chantent en duo
avec santerre il
serge avait conseillé à charlotte de ne
jamais prendre de cours de chant la
jeune fille devenue femme en a décidé
autrement
les accidents et le côté spontané ça
marche quand on est d'abord quand on est
guidé par par quelqu'un comme lui
si on est seul on il faut forcément être
beaucoup plus volontaire et donc j'ai
pris quelques cours charles gainsbourg
avec les unes des chansons un poème et
aucun fantôme le père même si je me
livre dans des chansons en tant que
femme explications et la fille a jamais
unis
c'est un fan ce jour